[Music]
hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check from gas masks psychics and cyborg
ninjas - octopus women and solar-powered
centenarian snipers Metal Gear Solid has
always had a bit of a fantastical take
on reality but that doesn't mean that
every aspect of the game has been
dredged from the dark recesses of Hideo
Kojima's brain let's take a look at some
of the Phantom Pain's tech that we can
use in real life sadly I don't think
science has advanced enough to make a
flying robotic fist just yet but I'm
sure we've got our top men working on it
our top men how do you take heavy stuff
home maybe stick it in a bag put it in
the back of a car well how's about
attaching it to a giant self inflating
helium balloon one of the Phantom Pain's
most useful meme worthy and funniest
gameplay systems the Fulton Erica free
system was actually used by the CIA back
in the 50s
CIA inventor Robert Edison Fulton jr.
built on earlier attempts by the Allied
forces to create fly by retrieval
systems and by 1958 came up with the
Fulton surface-to-air recovery system
package more commonly known as skyhook
no no not that skyhook the skyhook
package consisted of a harness a
500-foot nylon line tank of helium and
most importantly a deflated balloon it
kind of sounds a little bit like a
clown's toolkit
[Music]
anyway the plane used would have had
these sort of horns on the front which
would scoop up the line and a mechanism
would snap close on it releasing the
balloon and allowing for the person
package or sheep to be hauled into the
aircraft by the crew on board
skyhook was used by the CIA quite a few
times in the 50s and 60s most notably
during Operation cold feet something
that wouldn't be out of place in a Bond
movie it was where US agents had to use
the Fulton under treacherous snowy
conditions to extract Soviet equipment
from an abandoned Arctic research
facility sadly though after improvements
and increased availability in long-range
helicopters they gradually fell out of
style and out of use it simply wouldn't
be metal gear without nanomachines son
now the field of nanotechnology deals
with the study of matter that's on the
nano scale that is between 1 to 100
nanometers that is very difficult to
comprehend an atom is about Noor point 1
nanometers across this piece of paper
for example is a hundred thousand
nanometers thick so nanorobotics deals
with creating tiny machines on this
impossibly small nano scale that a
pre-programmed to perform a specific
task and they are of course a big huge
mainstay in the Metal Gear franchise now
nano machines at least in real life are
very much still in the R&D phase but the
industry is already worth billions and
there are some big plans on the horizon
theoretically none of watts could be
used in medicine to deliver chemotherapy
directly to the cancerous tissue
therefore minimizing the toxicity to the
rest of the body researchers also
believe that they'll be able to use them
to identify and repair damaged or
diseased tissues at the molecular level
so while this isn't being able to
interface with the Machine or being able
to live forever the possibility that we
could be able to identify and cure
disease from the inside is one that's
incredibly incredibly exciting and how's
about snakes bionic arm a veritable
Swiss Army knife of a prosthesis
it can be used to stun enemies teleport
them to your location and can even be
fired off like a remote-control rocket
to punch guys in the but sadly modern
prosthetics are nowhere near but
punching level but recent breakthroughs
in the field have led to some
potentially life-changing possibilities
for amputees DARPA an American research
agency response
well for coming up with technology for
the Department of Defense have been
working on revolutionising the field of
prosthetics while the technology to
control prosthetic limbs by thought
alone has been making great strides for
years there's always been one missing
key component the ability to feel which
is pretty crucial senses allow us to
create a feedback loop between us and
the world it's all very well for me to
hold this egg but for me to know how
much pressure to exert while holding it
my brain relies on the feel or the
feedback from the egg itself too little
and I drop it too much and without this
feedback it's difficult to perform
precise movements because you need that
element of control so DARPA found a 28
year old volunteer who's been paralyzed
for over 10 years and hooked up
electrodes to his sensory cortex that is
the area of the brain that deals with
senses like touch and smell as well as
to his motor cortex which controls body
movement and then attached all that to
especially created mechanical hand but
does it work while the volunteer could
tell with almost a hundred percent
accuracy which finger was being touched
when he was blindfolded not only that
but he responded that it was like his
own hand was being touched so again one
though rocket punches are so not just
yet this technology is the next step in
prosthetics many amputees report feeling
sensations including pain in the limbs
that they no longer have due to some
mixed up signals in the brain by hooking
up the brain sensory and motor cortex is
to the mechanical arm the brain kind of
sorts itself out and this pain is
eliminated and funnily enough feeling
sensations in lost limbs is known as the
phantom pain so those are just some
examples of some of the crazy metal gear
tech that we have access to least in
some capacity in our real lives luckily
for us I guess there aren't any of those
giant bipedal robots walking around for
more on Metal Gear Solid 5 why not take
a look at Jess's pics of the top Easter
eggs in the front in pain I've put a
link on the screen for you right now
thanks for watching this week's reality
check guys i'm on twitter at Lisa James
games I'll see you next time
[Music]